let's put it this way it is a a surefire
way
well that's not even true it was a
surefire way for me to enter the second
half of life
you know the first half of life i spent
building up this persona
and this ego and this container and
now i've entered a section of my life
where i figure out
what goes in that container what i want
to fill it with
what the purpose is
for for myself what what type of
impact do i want to have on the on the
world around me
um and what type of um
values do i want to instill and pass
along to this new person
who is going to have his own uh his own
path and
his own struggles and his own pain and
his own
anxieties um and can i
can i uh die
into myself enough can i kill my ego
enough
to get out of the way and
and help be an emotional
coach or an emotional support a mentor
for this new being now look yeah you're
making it sound like look obviously this
is
fantastic but you'd be kidding yourself
not to say
it it can't be easy i mean so far it's
pretty easy because
really well he he doesn't communicate
yet
so that's gonna be the hardest thing i
wish i knew what you wanted what's the
matter why are you crying
well when he cries it's very it's very
brief
okay you're lucky yeah you're one of
those people and they have a second kid
and it's damien from the old woman of
course
and and he he let's put this way he
can't speak yet but he can't
he does communicate very well he he he
fusses when he needs something
and usually he only needs one of three
things you know food sleep or
or or a new set of clothes um
and that's easy that that part's easy so
what has been difficult is bear requires
my constant attention
when he is not sleeping even when he's
sleeping
which means that whatever i'm doing
you know worrying about the future
regretting the past
running around busying myself
i'm constantly being brought back to the
present moment
that ceases that's that's done that
doesn't cease it like
it like fires you know ac dc alternate
current it like okay
okay here okay i can focus on now i'm
immediately brought back to the moment
is that frustrating no well it was at
first because
i would get i would get frustrated with
myself
i would get impatient and then i just
realized aha
this moment this is uh this is all there
is is this moment
and so bear is just here reminding me of
that
come back come back come back come back
to this moment come back to now
okay yeah take care of that and come
back uh yeah you can worry for a second
your your my mind can wander for a
minute but there's this child
you know and and it at first it was
frustrating and then i just realized
where else where else would i where else
could i go where else do i want to be
than right here right you know that's
been a big part of the paradigm shift is
you know when
when you call and you say hey come over
to the house hang out let's do a podcast
i have to think to myself is that two
hours
that i want to spend away from bear wow
like so the answer was yes the answer
was yeah
well the answer is the answer is is this
going to feed feed me
in a way that makes it valuable enough
to be away from bear sure